last week M80 officially unveiled their
long rumored entry into professional
Counter-Strike and just as said rumors
suggested their roster is hot up and
coming and of course North American
which is great really we'd love to see
these types of Surgeons the question is
whether it's too late with liquid moving
to EU and EG and complexity still
struggling to find their footing
you can't help but wonder is an ACS
finally really truly past the point of
no return
[Music]
okay so before we get into the video our
friends over at at T are putting on the
third annual at T Annihilator cup
happening every Thursday in July tune in
as 20 of your favorite creators like
Tariq it's Timmy and lyric play
different games for Glory bragging
rights and real cash you can also watch
the content we will be making about the
cup throughout the month to keep up with
all of the best moments so you don't
miss out okay so
nacs home of the whiffed shot missed
smoke and self-inflicted Molly eu's
favorite meme look it's no secret that
North American Esports in general is one
of the biggest memes in Competitive
Gaming it's also no secret that North
American Counter-Strike in particular
is just on a special storied level of
sad it's almost as bad as any League
almost the reason for this is actually
very simple throughout the 20 plus year
history of Counter-Strike
it's never really been that popular in
North America the European player base
has pretty much always been like 10
times larger than North Americas which
is why y'all are so much damn better yes
I know you like to think it's because of
genetics but I assure you it's not
because y'all play the game we
are scrubs not because we're valorante
enthusiasts who are afraid of realism
and dark corridor
I mean we are but because until very
recently the prevalence of PC gaming in
North America was vastly outweighed by
that of console gaming okay so why am I
saying all of this because even the
highs 15 year old nothing CGS the early
days of go C9 winning the major liquid
speed running the slam we're basically
flashes in the pan nacs has sort of
always just been getting by and then
covid and the cartoon shooter came along
and dealted a very serious blow
everything moved online and or to Europe
and made it impossible to be
simultaneously North American and
sustainable from 100 thieves to chaos
Esports never forget
org started dropping out like flies
there were holdouts of course Grassroots
hopefuls like party astronauts ATK and
Bad News Bears but by the time
everything shook out there were
basically three upper tier rosters
carrying the entire scene on their
shoulders complexity Evil Geniuses
and Team Liquid now in terms of
international presence it's fair to say
that Team Liquid were pretty much
single-handedly shouldering the hopes
and dreams of nacs they weren't the only
good team but they were the only great
team
that is until a couple of weeks ago when
they dropped a liege and moved to EU I
made it to Anatomy specifically about
that move which you can check out if
you're so inclined but suffice it to say
it might be the worst blow that nacs has
ever endured seriously it left the
region
sad bewildered and in some cases
outright betrayed the scene was thrust
into an extremely tenuous place so much
so that since liquid's departure a huge
portion of the community has started to
wonder whether it might eventually be
regarded as the death knell of nacs so
let's talk about it is nacs for all
intents and purposes
answer is no it's not dead not yet since
moving to complexity a liege has
elevated this feisty group of mostly
North American Misfits into a real
hopeful and whether the result of
mismanagement or otherwise EG's decision
to promote Academy players in lieu of
signing European heavyweights is an
interesting one that at the very least
keeps North America on the board I agree
with Valance that it could prove to be a
super interesting story and then late
last week M80 announced that they would
be doing exactly what it was rumored
they'd be doing signing a world-class
CS2 roster all right world class might
be a bit of an overstatement but the
roster is great and crucially North
American and let's just say that
domestically
they're off to a pretty strong start
like snakes they could bring this in
Lake knows where one will play Isabel
Swisher he's got the awp coming alive
foreign
comes down first you've got Swisher who
many are regarding as Na's next breakout
Talent so much so in fact that people
were actually hoping liquid might
consider him as a Nitro replacement then
there's monks the former Copenhagen
flame who turned more than a few heads
on ecstatic and mobs the Team One slash
zero zero Nation entry Fragger who is
just cracked then you've got Wolfie
who's coming from fnatic rising and
wreck who's still looking for that
chance to prove himself at a high level
and of course death as the coach all in
all an exciting roster genuinely will
they save North American Counter-Strike
probably not but they don't have to they
just have to do that thing that chaos
did Once Upon a Time and become the
darling roster that everyone roots for
the locally sourced grass-fed one that
proves there actually can be a future
for the scene the question as to whether
nacs can be saved isn't on any one
roster it's on CS as a whole more
specifically CS2 look I'm not gonna sit
here and say that North American CS is
back baby just you wait because I don't
know if that's true what I do know is
that orgs such as M80 aren't
Psychopathic for betting on CS2 we saw
what valerians did for North American
Esports and there is zero reason to
think that CS2 couldn't do the same
competitors are eyeing comebacks
streamers new and old are opening cases
like they're going out of style which
let me assure you they're not North
American Counter-Strike is primed for a
Revival and there is no reason to think
that all of this casual engagement
couldn't inject new life into the
competitive scene to be clear a huge
reason as to why liquid left are because
they weren't interested in sitting
around and waiting for that to happen
liquid don't want to be a poster child
for a region on life support they want
to win now not a year or two from now
and right now the only way to do that
is to move to Europe but it doesn't mean
that it will stay that way forever call
it copium because it is but I believe in
nacs I believe that there is an audience
for this franchise in this continent I
know that because
I'm talking to them right now you're
hungry you're passionate and most
importantly you're growing now don't get
me wrong it's not gonna be easy it's not
as if CS2 will come out and just
magically fix everything overnight it's
not just us who needs to care valve
needs to care ESL needs incentive to
re-establish a pro league so that it's
sustainable for competitors to care can
all of this happen yes will it
I don't know but I hold out hope because
that is what it means to be someone who
loves Counter-Strike
and lives in this part of the world is
nacs dead
no is it close
yes in the same way that it's always
been
maybe a tad War but remember what they
say in the iron Islands what is dead may
never die but rises again harder and
stronger
I buy like 7 000 hours into two I just
like and I played DOTA All-Stars for
like years before that right so like I'm
just like I'm just I love watching it
still I just I'm sort of just tired I
just don't really want to play anymore
and league is just easy to like kind of
surround in and try new stuff and